sundae's fiery slaughter slayed in the
ratings with a record eighteen point
four million viewers tuning in that
number gets even bigger when you add in
DVR views season 8 is averaging 43
million viewers per episode that's 10
million more than last season oh my
goodness all this even though fan
reaction to what they're tuning in for
isn't great last Sunday's episode got
the lowest score of the entire season on
Rotten Tomatoes with a 47 percent
approval rating sorry with many fans not
liking Danny's people shift in fact
there's now a petition for HBO to redo
the final season it has 45,000
signatures and Counting and get this
when you googled the words bad writers
an image of the G ot co-creators pops up
their intentions were good
Sunday's finale episode Koster reported
15 million dollars to make and bran is
currently the odd makers favorite to end
up on the Iron Throne
followed by Jon Snow but did two other
shows predict the finale years ago in
2017 The Simpsons
seemingly predicted the fall of King's
Landing in a scene that looked nearly
identical to what viewers saw on Sunday
look the dragon is burning our village
and check out this Parks and Rec
prediction from 2015 oh my god babe Game
of Thrones is on tonight it's the series
finale Khaleesi is marrying Jack Sparrow
that [ __ ] was really gone off the rails
[Music]